let's face it Red Dead 2 has too many
things to do
you can barely step foot in the game
without being pulled in a million
different directions
it's a neurotics nightmare I'm telling
you but for those who'd rather simply
explore the land take in the sights and
maybe even discover a couple secrets
along the way we've got just the thing
for you now keep in mind
nobody likes spoiled eggs so if you'd
rather hunt for these on your own
what the hell are you doing here stop
watching this video and maybe check out
our let's play series dirty arty instead
okay here are seven of the best Easter
eggs we found so far in Red Dead
Redemption tube now as you might
remember from John Marston his time in
new Austin
swimming was a little bit dangerous to
say the least and Rockstar is very well
aware of that as they added a line of
dialogue poking fun at marcin's aversion
to water can't swim kids no more
thankfully Red Dead Redemption 2 allows
you to swim but Arthur isn't about to
let us forget about what we had to go
through in the first game there are a
number of Fantasy references in the game
including one that pays tribute to one
of our favorite junior our Tolkien
characters hobbits up in the hills near
Donner Falls you'll find a little
hillside home that looks very much like
the ones in lore of the Rings sadly
there are no hobbitses in sight but
Arthur will sketch out the house in his
journal leave him to ponder who might be
living there also there's a painting on
the back that looks like a turtle or
maybe a UFO yes you heard me we are not
alone in this universe but that's not to
say we didn't see it coming if you head
over to this cabin near emerald ranch
you'll be greeted with a bunch of
rotting corpses and the letter
explaining their otherworldly reasons
for drinking the home unbranded
non-carbonated fruit flavored soft drink
so to speak but all you have to do is
come back at 2 a.m. to catch a glimpse
of a hovering UFO if you want an even
better look at the spacecraft head on up
to the peak of Mount Shan and directly
after seeing the green glow in the cabin
and wait till 1:00 a.m. the next day
don't forget to snap a photo while
you're up there
are the UFOs part of a bigger mystery or
are they just another tiny footnote in
the game of densely packed world we'll
let you decide on that one speaking of
mysteries players spent years searching
for Bigfoot in the GTA series but in Red
Dead 2 he's right under our noses well
at least we think so if you're still
atop Mount Shan searching for UFOs you
can also find some bones of some kind of
giant tucked away in the corner of the
peak this may seem a little
disappointing to some if you're to
believe these belong to the famous
sasquatch but hold on there's more way
up north at the Calumet ravine visit the
spot right here then make your way over
to this mysterious cavern tucked away in
the mountains who's in there you might
wonder well why don't we just ask is
that so is it the legendary Bigfoot
maybe the Sasquatch from undead
nightmare or maybe it's just a super
insecure guy with a pituitary gland
problem whoever the mystery voice
belongs to we only really know that he's
a large man all right mr. big man it was
nice chatting with you and all but we've
gotta get going there is a ghost that
needs our attention wait what ghosts yes
there are some very haunted spirits
lurking in the mists deep in the Lemoine
swamps if you head up the Kumasi river
and near the border of New Hanover you
might hear a spooky voice calling that's
Agnes Dowd Agnes seems to have some
unfinished business as her dialogue
tells a somber tale of love and
heartache if you're in the mood for
sadness you can visit her every two days
in the swamps but she'll only appear if
it's a particularly foggy night so try
to get there between 10:00 p.m. and 4:00
a.m.
after she finishes telling her tale
she's gone forever so don't miss it now
if you're on the hunt for more sad
Easter eggs here's one more just south
the flat next station in the heartland
there's a corpse washed up on the beach
but try and Luda and whoa this one's
still alive as it turns out the dying
man appears to be the former lover of
Bonnie McFarlane whom you might remember
as the farmhand from Red Dead one that
helps John out early on in the game the
letter he hands you talks of him and
Bonnie destined for each other that
they're meant to be together raising
kids and that he's determined to make a
fortune and set things straight between
them unfortunately as you can tell that
never happens
his final resting spot is not on the bed
with Bonnie by his side but rather on
the beach broke disheveled and alone
sorry to bum you all out with that
Easter egg um how about we end on the
fun one okay so we've established that
aliens exist so there's got to be other
extraterrestrial happenings in the game
right well if you make your way over to
Roanoke Valley in northern and this burg
you can find remnants of a meteor crash
the family living in the home where it
landed certainly won't mind you snooping
around as they're all kind of dead at
the moment so feel free to check out the
space rock for yourself and maybe even
bring home a souvenir or two so those
were just some of the many many Easter
eggs hidden in the far corners of Red
Dead Redemption twos map if you found
one that people need to know about leave
it in the comments below and we might
get to it in a future video until then
though happy hunting and don't forget to
check out gamespot.com
for more Red Dead Redemption 2 features
and guides thanks for watching
you